hey you know what
i needed the work
johnny depp makes a surprise appearance
at the 2022 vmas and he's really
committing to his latest role as moon
man during sunday's ceremony you have to
take it all very seriously you know the
actors brief cameo as the full-size
astronaut follows epic opening
performances from jack harlow and fergie
[Applause]
[Music]
check out johnny's big reveal as he
floats down from the rafters
you know what
i needed the work
after joking he quote needed the work
later in the show he appears again this
time offering a list of jobs he's
available for
i just want you guys to know that i'm
available for birthdays bar mitzvahs
batman's was weddings wakes
any old thing you need
anything
[Applause]
you name it
so
oh i'm also a dentist
yeah he totally takes a jab at himself
referencing his career comeback after
winning his high-profile defamation case
against amber heard in june a source
told et def was quote looking forward to
the future both personally and
professionally and feels like he got his
career back earlier this month it was
announced johnny would direct his first
film in 25 years modi
plus he's returning to the big screen as
king louis xv and john du berry while
fans await his big acting return
let's embrace johnny depp the moon man
hey you know what
i needed the work
[Music]